en afghanistan en suspension du projet
de gazoduc censé relier le turkménistan
au pakistan et à l'inde en cause la
situation chaotique à kaboul plus de
précisions sur place avec notre envoyé
spécial antoine clairon ce projet de
gazoduc est un véritable serpent de mer
en effet cela fait plus de vingt ans
qu'on en parle et la première pierre n'a
toujours pas été posée l'idée c'est de
faire parvenir le gaz du turkménistan ce
pays producteurs qui détient les 4e
réserves mondiales de gaz naturel vers
des pays gourmand en énergie comme le
pakistan et l'inde mais voilà pour faire
parvenir ce gaz naturel il faut passer
via l'afghanistan l'afghanistan ce pays
à la stabilité toute relative comme l'a
encore rappelé le ministre pakistanais
des affaires économiques
selon les informations dont nous
disposons pour le moment en afghanistan
personne ne travaille sur ce projet ou
sur d'autres projets beaucoup de gens
ont été évacués et la banque mondiale
n'a plus de représentant en afghanistan
quand nous aurons stabiliser la
situation
nous pourrons revenir sur la question de
la construction mais pour l'instant le
projet a été suspendu jusqu'à ce que la
situation soit éclaircie
il ya tout d'abord un volet sécuritaire
même si depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir des
talibans la situation tend à se
stabiliser il ne faut pas oublier que ce
sont ces mêmes talibans qui était la
cause de cette instabilité épuisé la
menace de l'état islamique qui perpétue
régulièrement des attaques terroristes
contre les nouvelles autorités il ya
également le volet économique en effet
l'économie afghane est en lambeaux en
grande partie à cause des sanctions
internationales décidées contre kaboul
une crise économique qui pourrait se
doubler d'une crise humanitaire dans les
prochaines semaines dans les prochains
mois autant dire que les priorités des
nouvelles autorités ne sont pas des
investissements dans les infrastructures
mais plutôt tout d'abord de pouvoir
nourrir sa population